he tweeted quote suffering results for
one part of the Mind failing at
regulating another part of the Mind
suffering happens at an early stage of
mental development I don't think that
superhuman AI would suffer what's uh
your intuition there
the philosopher Thomas metzinga is very
concerned that the creation of
superhuman intelligence would lead to
superhuman suffering yeah and so he is
strongly against it and personally I
don't think that this happens because
suffering is not happening at the
boundary between
ourselves and the physical Universe it's
not stuff on our skin that makes us
suffer it happens at the boundary
between self and world right and the
world here is the world model it's the
stuff that is created by your mind but
that's all presentation of how the
universe is and how it should be and how
you yourself relate to this and at this
boundary is where suffering happens
so suffering in some sense is
self-inflicted but not by yourself it's
inflicted by the mind on the personal
self that experiences itself as you and
you can turn off suffering when you are
able to get on this outer level
so when you manage to
understand
how the mind is producing
pain and pleasure and fear and love and
so on then you can take charge of this
and you get agency or whether you're a
suffer
technically what a pain and pleasure is
there are learning signals right the
part of your brain is standing a
learning a signal to another part of the
brain to improve its performance
and
sometimes this doesn't work because this
trainers will sense the signal does not
have a good model of how to improve the
performance so it's sending a signal but
the performance doesn't get better
and then it might crank up the pain and
it gets worse and worse and the behavior
of the system uh maybe even
deteriorating as a result but until this
is resolved the speculation issue your
pain is increasing and this is I think
typically what you describe as suffering
so in this sense you could say that pain
is very natural and helpful but
suffering is the result of a regulation
problem in which you try to regulate
something that cannot actually be
regulated and that could be resolved if
you would be able to
get at the level of your mind where the
pain signal is being created and
rerouted and improve the regulation and
a lot of people get there right if you
are a monk who is spending decades
reflecting about how their own psyche
works you can get to the point where
you're they realize that suffering is
really a choice and you can choose how
your mind is set up and I don't think
that AI would stay in the state where
the personal self doesn't get agency or
this model of what the system has about
itself it doesn't get agency how it's
actually implemented I wouldn't stay in
that state for very long so it goes to
the stages real quick well to seven
stages it's going to go to Enlightenment
real quick yeah of course there might be
a lot of stuff happening in between
because if you have a system that works
at a much higher frame rate than us
then even though it looks for visual to
us maybe for the system there's a much
longer subjective time
which things are unpleasant what is the
thing that we recognize as super
intelligent is actually living in at
stage five that the thing that's at
stage six Enlightenment is not very
productive so in order to be productive
with society and impress us with this
power it has to be a reasoning
self-authoring agent the enlightenment
makes you lazy as an agent in the world
well of course it makes you lazy because
you no longer see the point in
um so it doesn't make you not lazy it
just um in some sense adapts you to what
you perceive as your true circumstances
so what of all agis they they're only
productive as they progress through one
two three four five and the moment they
get to six they just kind of it's a
failure mode essentially as far as
humans are concerned because they're
just start chilling they're like it
I'm out
not necessarily I suspect that the monks
who are self-emulated for their
political beliefs to make statements
about the occupation of Tibet by China
um they're probably being able to
regulate their physical pain in any way
they wanted to and uh suffering was a
spiritual suffering that was the result
of their choice that they made of what
they wanted to identify as so stage five
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
no identity anymore but you can choose
your identity you can make it
instrumental to the world that you want
to have